guys this video is made possible by the
heroes over a bag blaze just go to bag
blaze calm /by graphics and get hooked
up with unlimited backup for six dollars
a month and a 15-day free trial to test
it out
don't delay do it today and let's get
into today's video it's the first of
October 1938 Heston Airport just outside
of London a man steps out of a propeller
airplane to address a crowd of
journalists officials and onlookers
he waves in triumph a piece of paper
carrying two signatures his and the
other one for a certain mr. a Hitler the
man is hailed as a national hero as he
announces that he has truly achieved
peace for our times this man whose
status as a hero will soon be critiqued
by none other than Winston Churchill is
the current British Prime Minister
Neville Chamberlain his just signed an
agreement with the German governments
preventing a war in Europe at least for
the moment but sacrificing the young
state of Czechoslovakia to Nazi demands
Neville Chamberlain has become
synonymous with the ill-advised policy
of appeasement an emblem of the West's
weakness when faced by the aggressive
bullying of the Axis powers but in the
video today we look at whether this
infamy is really deserved
Arthur Neville Chamberlain was born in
Birmingham England on March the 18th
1869 in a wealthy politically involved
family although they were not part of
the aristocracy his father Joseph was a
cabinet minister during Queen Victoria's
reign who had married twice having a
total of six children there is Beatrice
in Austen from a previous marriage and
then Neville and three daughters Ethel
Ida and Hilda from his second wife as
was tradition at that time it was down
to the boys to perpetrate the trade and
traditions of the family Austen novels
older half-brother was the ones who
initially carry out the political
ambitions of the Chamberlain's he took
up a string of civil service and
political posts culminating his career
as foreign secretary in the 1920s he was
the mastermind behind the Treaty of
lucano between Great Britain France
fiema Germany Italy and Belgium which
earns him a Nobel Peace Prize Neville on
the other hand was expected to take the
reins of the family's main business
enterprises he perfected his education
first at the Rugby School and then at
Mason College now the University of
Birmingham coming from a privileged
family does not guarantee happiness
though and it was reported that never
was an introverted shy boy whose school
years were plagued by incidents of
bullying after his formative years aged
only twenty-one Neville was tasked by
his father to manage one of the
Chamberlain's business enterprises this
would be a daunting task for anyone but
it might have been made lighter by the
fact that the job involved managing a
plantation in the Bahamas this must have
been quite fun the young Neville but
unfortunately after some years that
business venture had ultimately failed
Neville had anyhow proven himself to be
a talented manager and supervisor after
returning to England he would put that
experience to successful use first in
the private sector and then following
Austin's footsteps into politics in 1911
Neville Chamberlain secured his first
political post by winning a seat in the
Birmingham City Council in that same
year he married and their Col with whom
you would later have two children
Dorothea and Francis Chamberlain's next
step was to secure a higher position in
local politics which he did by becoming
Lord Mayor of Birmingham in 1915 by now
aged 49 he was too old to serve in World
War one but he did contribute to the war
effort as director of the national
service and appointment awarded directly
by prime minister Louis
this job involved compulsion which is
basically the equivalent of conscription
for war industries however all of
Chamberlin's attempts to drive
compulsory labor into industries vital
to the war effort were hampered by the
unions by the War Cabinet or by annoyed
George himself apparently the two men
could not stand each other after
Chamberlain finally resigned in August
of 1917 Lloyd George wrote to his family
Chamberlain has resigned and thank God
for that
Chamberlain referred to the prime
minister as such that dirty little Welsh
attorney this experience almost deterred
him to stay clear of politics but he
made a comeback into public life by
winning a seat in the House of Commons
in 1918 as a member of the Conservative
Party from then on his career was on the
rise in 1922 he became Postmaster
General in Andrew Berner laws government
attest that he passed with flying colors
becoming Minister of Health within
months and shortly afterwards Chancellor
of the Exchequer all of this was done in
little more than a year and within at
five years of his entering Parliament
and just by the way for those who are
not familiar with the workings of the
British government the Chancellor of the
Exchequer is sort of the secretary or
the minister in charge of the economy so
it's big deal Chamberlain retained this
post for the following years and did
very well in 1929 he reformed the so
called poor law which laid down the
foundations for the welfare state in the
crisis that followed the Wall Street
Crash he protected the fragile state of
British industry by passing the import
duties bill in 1932 all of this hard
work it paid off and in May of 1937
Neville Chamberlain was elected leader
of the Conservative Party and succeeded
Stanley Baldwin as prime minister his
early efforts they were a continuation
of his welfare reforms for example the
factories Act of 1937 restricted the
number of hours that children and women
worked and in 1938 Chamberlain supported
the holiday with pay Act which gave
workers a week off with pay so by
looking at his careers so far you could
see how the shy boy from rugby school
had turned into an active and ambitious
leader willing to bring about
improvements to the society around him
by breaking with established traditions
however his achievements on the domestic
front were about to be overshadowed by a
looming crisis in a faraway land
all right so I'm not gonna chart here
the rise of Hitler in the Nazi Party and
how the new German government
immediately started making plans for
territorial annexation so I'll tell you
a bit more about that in a bit for now
let's just scroll our Google Maps south
of Berlin and instead look at the
Sudetenland region instead this is a
region in then Czechoslovakia which
bordered with Germany and was home to
some three million ethnic Germans back
in 1931 a sue Dayton German called
Konrad Henlein had founded the Sudeten
Germans people party which advocated for
the region to secede and be annexed by
Germany needless to say in the following
decade Nazi leadership had openly
supported and lines caused short Germans
on both sides of the Czechoslovak border
wanted to be reunited but the push for
annexations had far more materialistic
reasons which worried the government in
Prague the SU Dayton region was home to
the lignite and coal mines it was also
the most heavily defended meaning a
peaceful annexation to Germany it would
have granted at a convenient stepping
stone to annex the whole of
Czechoslovakia so I would Nazi Germany
he's so interested in absorbing that
small young Central European state well
that would be Skoda
today these guys manufacture affordable
city cars but back then the Skoda works
were one of the largest armament
manufacturers in Europe the production
volume of Skoda works between August
1938 in September 1939 alone was nearly
equal to that of all British Arsenal
factories in that period and sorry to
jump ahead here but in 1939 a certain
Hermann Goering made a nice little
profit by acquiring shares in Skoda so
I'm gonna venture a personal observation
here and say the Nazi leadership Spain
interest was probably not the well-being
of Konrad Henlein in the SU Dayton
Germans but rather to replenish their
Arsenal's and their pockets parts let's
get back to the crisis in late summer
1938 the Nazi Party asked Heinlein to
stir some trouble as a means to create
an excuse for a military invasion the
governments of Edouard Benish and Prague
had created a system of defensive
alliance with France and the Soviet
Union but neither of them was really
keen to intervene should an invasion a
car Chamberlain was well aware that if
France did intervene also Britain would
be dragged into a European war which not
only himself but his whole cabinet and
majority of the public opinion were keen
to avoid at all costs the British prime
minister then took the initiative to
lead a series of negotiations throughout
September of 1938 to prevent an armed
conflict the first meeting with Hitler
took place at Bursch this garden near
Munich had this meeting Hitler demanded
that the Sudetenland should be handed
over to Germany without consulting at
Vaught Benesch Chamberlain agreed that
those areas contained more than 50%
Germans and should be handed back to
Germany Chamberlain managed to get the
Czechs and the French to agree to this
solution on September the 22nd
Chamberlain flew again to Germany to
meet Hitler so that the final details of
the plan could be worked out Hitler had
a very low opinion of Chamberlain
describing him in private as I know
schlock and so it was no surprise that
the Fuehrer stuns the Prime Minister
with a whole new set of demands these
were number 1 German troops were to
occupy the Sudetenland number 2 Czech
lands containing a majority of poles and
Hungarians should be returned to Poland
and Hungary effectively Hitler was
demanding for a dissolution of
Czechoslovakia this time Chamberlain and
French president de la da rejected these
demands the stalemate was unlocked by
Benito Mussolini he proposed an
emergency conference in Munich to reach
an agreement once and for all the
participants were Germany Great Britain
France and Italy and can you spot the
missing guests yes you're absolutely
right that was beat Czechoslovakia they
were not invited and neither was the
Soviet Union which also pissed off
Joseph Stalin
without consulting the Czechs the four
powers agreed that the Sudetenland
should be given to Germany immediately
the governments of Britain and France
made it clear to Czechs that if they
rejected this solution they would have
to fight Germany by themselves this was
the crowning moments of the policy of
appeasement on October the 1st 1938
German troops occupied the Sudetenland
polish and Hungarian troops also
occupied areas of Czechoslovakia which
contained the majority of poles and
Mayas the dismemberment of
Czechoslovakia was complete when Germany
formally annexed what is today the Czech
Republic in March of 1939 while sabaha
seceded and became an axis Ally so let's
return to our earlier scene Chamberlain
is waving that piece of paper the newly
signed agreements at Heston Airport to
him it's a former guarantee of peace in
our time in Europe so Hitler is just a
scrap a paper now back in the day
chamber
was probably all like guys we should get
some copies of this just in case we lose
it I mean crack out the team of people
who copy things word-for-word I'm
assuming they didn't have photocopiers
back then maybe they did who knows but
losing your documents isn't something
that you need to worry about if you're
like me and you have today's sponsor
Backblaze and it's not just losing files
but it also protects you from a hard
disk failure or theft of your laptop or
god forbid your house burns down or
something like that all of your data
will be secure if you have Bagley's now
I always try out the sponsors that we
have on this channel but I've actually
been using Backblaze for years way
before they sponsored this video way
before they sponsored any of my videos
and I went to them because I looked
around and they were the best option why
well I don't want to have to think about
backups I just wanted software to run in
the background and do it or boy I have
an absolute ton of data terabytes and
terabytes of stuff and so I really
needed unlimited backup and I also
needed it to be cheap because I am a
cheap person Backblaze is cheap at $6 a
month it's truly unlimited there's no
that fair use stuff I don't know if you
guys have ever got an angry letter from
your ISP for downloading too much on
your unlimited plan I have this is truly
unlimited there are no caps with
Backblaze and it also does just run in
the background I usually leave it to
just run from I think it's about 8 p.m.
to 6:00 in the morning just backing off
my files while I'm asleep all together
they've backed up 750 billion megabytes
which is I don't know almost in
conceptive Lee is that even a word I
can't even conceive how big that is now
on the thing is you really hope you
never need their backup but if you do
you can download it or if it's a ton of
data they will ship a hard disk to you
so you know easy way to get that data
fast and it's all encrypted of course in
case anyone you know nefarious gets
their hands on that it'll just be
useless to them also you hang on a 15
day free trial to see if it's for you
through our link and just do it go to
bag blaze calm /bi graphics
get set up it's just a good peace of
mind and let's get back to Chamberlain
[Music]
it's easy to say with the power of
hindsight the Chamberlain's decision was
a completely wrong one on a moral level
the Western powers as members of the
League of Nations and allied of
Czechoslovakia had a duty to step in and
protect an allied country or other
member state from aggressions and
demands worthy of a schoolyard bully on
a practical level the matter is far more
complicated but it also weighs against
Chamberlain now the assumption that
Britain and France were not ready for a
full-scale war especially with Germany
may have been correct and it is
understandable that Chamberlain and
ilaria were keen to avoid another mess
like world war one the British prime
minister had a particular fear of the
destruction of civilian targets that
could be caused by the new tactics of
war from the air it seems that upon
returning from his first flight to
Munich he observed how easy it would
have been for a bomber to hit the heart
of London one of his military advisers
even told him that two months of bombing
raids would have caused one million
victims but Germany itself was not ready
for a war with the West in the autumn of
1938 the Vere market was much weaker
than it appeared from Goebbels
propaganda reels a full mechanization of
the here.or land forces on the basis of
general Guderian's doctrine it was still
on the horizon
more importantly the hyelin's of the
armed forces were not a united front
supporting the Nazi Party it is reported
in fact that the army chief of staff
general Franz Halder was planning to
eliminate Hitler ins even carried a
loaded gun with him at all times should
the occasion arise in September and
October of 1938 the German High Command
was fully aware of the country's
relative weakness and did not welcome
the prospect of war with Czechoslovakia
even if Britain and France did not come
to the rescue
Czechoslovakia may have been a small
country but its army was well-trained
well-equipped and well defended by
fortifications now did Chamberlain know
all of this but apparently he did
receive a report from mi5 detailing
Aldus plans but would that have been
enough to have changed the opinion of
Chamberlain and the majority of the
cabinet more importantly would that have
been enough to change the course of
eight years of foreign policy dedicated
to her appearance
[Music]
Neville Chamberlain became synonymous
with appeaser but certainly he wasn't
the first political leader neither in
Great Britain nor elsewhere to pursue a
policy of appeasement in the face of a
military threat so let's just jump into
a brief history of appeasement here
round one Japanese invasion of Manchuria
in 1931 an explosion on the South
Manchuria railway gave the Japanese
military the perfect excuse to invade
this Chinese regions you protect
Japanese interests in the area it was
all a part of a plan of aggression to
expand Tokyo sphere of influence provide
an outlet for the booming population and
provide new markets for a struggling
industrial sector the League of Nations
intervention was initially bens on
economic sanctions which Britain and
France did not endorse fearsome of
losing trade with Japan or even
provoking a full-scale invasion of
British colonies in the Far East and
what was the results well this was a
weak plan to create a semi-independent
state in Manchuria which Japan rejected
by quitting the League of Nations and
going on to complete the invasion of the
region and establishing a puppet state
bound to held Anschluss attempt in 1934
not one year in power and Hitler and the
Nazi government were already been zhan
annexing Austria their plans kicked off
with an attempted coup carried out by
Austrian Nazis which were obviously
funded and directed from Berlin the
conspirators even managed to assassinate
the Prime Minister and German troops
were ready to move in the Western powers
again did not intervene so of all people
but an end to this first Angelus well
you might be surprised that was Benito
Mussolini who at this time was not yet
allied to Germany and was instead tied
to Vienna in a protective treaty
Mussolini deployed to alpine troop
divisions on the Austrian border and the
still weak Vere Marx had to hit the
brakes round three Italy invades
Ethiopia 1935 yesterday the defender
today the attacker a border incident
with Ethiopia gave Mussolini the excuse
to order an invasion of Ethiopia in
October of 1935 British public opinion
was in favor to intervene against
fascist Italy it would have been dead
easy just shutting down the Suez Canal
to Italian shipping would have put an
end to the invasion but Prime Minister
Baldwin he didn't want to alienate
Mussolini and his anti German stomps
many intervention was delegated to the
League of Nations
marna goshi ations dragged on into 1936
the Ethiopian capital Addis Ababa
fell in May of 1936 rounds for Hitler
retakes the Rhinelands March 1936 the
Rhinelands includes the border areas
with the Low Countries which were meant
to stay demilitarized as per the Treaty
of Versailles but taking advantage of
the Ethiopian crisis the German army
just up and went they took a huge gamble
by the way the marching units carried
rifles loaded with blanks and at strict
orders to retreat immediately at the
slightest sign of Franco British
resistance but resistance it did not
materialize the occupation it was
carried out and Germany gains a huge
advantage in preparation for the water
come round 6 Japan invades the rest of
China 1937
what started as minor clashes between
the Imperial Japanese Army and the
Chinese nationalist forces in July of
that year quickly escalated into a
full-blown invasion as usual the Western
powers the Soviet Union the League of
Nations they just looked on while the
Japanese carried out indiscriminate
bombing of civilian targets
interestingly helped the trying
kai-shek's Chinese nationalists came
from Nazi Germany in the shape of
training and supplies round seven the
successful Angeles in March of 1938 when
Germany incorporated Austria the West
remained silenced and Italy it was now
on the side of the invader but now
Chamberlain had replaced Baldwin as
Prime Minister and as you may have
guessed he simply continued with the
same policy put into practice by his
predecessors and fellow member states of
the League of Nations in addition to the
desire of avoiding a major war on the
continents Chamberlain was also
motivated by compensating Germany in
some way for the harsh treatment imposed
by the Treaty of Versailles moreover one
of the key principles of the post-world
War One World Order was
self-determination based on that
principle wasn't it lawful to allow
German minorities to reunite with their
motherland now now for just one more
bonus round the Spanish Civil War of
1936 to 1939 now we could talk for hours
on end about this war but I'll make just
one point Italy Germany and the Soviet
Union all intervened heavily supporting
opposing factions with troops weapons
and money on the other hands Britain and
France simply forbid the supply of arms
to either side this non-interventionist
policy was a continuation of Baldwin's
plan not to alienate muster
sympathy stands well yeah how are to
treat dinner and now let's zoom back in
to London and fast forward to the 3rd of
September 1939 Neville Chamberlain has
just announced on the radio the Great
Britain is now at war with Germany all
of his efforts to maintain peace in
Europe were all in vain in the end
Chamberlain's leadership during the war
is considered lackluster at best and
these months were called the so-called
phony war in which French and British
troops did little but stand by the
Maginot Line waiting for a German attack
however it is fair to recognize one
important victory which can be
attributed to Chamberlain's foresight
the Battle of Britain or the months long
duel in which the royal air force
established air superiority over the
Luftwaffe thus preventing operations
ceylon the invasion of Great Britain in
the months after the Munich Treaty
Chamberlain led the developments of
Britain's air defense systems the most
sophisticated in Europe it was thanks to
him that the Royal Air Force could rely
on the revolutionary invention of radar
to coordinate wave after wave of
Spitfire fighter planes against incoming
German squadrons but evolution Berlin
could not reap the reward for such a
success on the 10th of May 1940 after a
failed attempt to reclaim Norway from
Nazi occupation Chamberlain resigned
Winston Churchill the main architect of
the Norwegian debacle became the new
Prime Minister Chamberlain continued to
serve in Churchill's cabinet but
resigned for good
in October of 1942 ill with late-stage
bowel cancer not one month later on the
9th of November Chamberlain died in his
estate near Reading in southern England
now you might think that it's really
easy to just dismiss Neville Chamberlain
as a gullible man a naive apisa who did
not respond to Hitler's provocations for
all the wrong reasons but the reality
now is far more complex and it's
understandable how appeasement may have
been considered as the best option at
that time however Chamberlain had a
record for breaking away with
established policies and had he listened
to other opinions rather than the
conservative majority he could have
changed the course of history for the
better
Winston Churchill probably summarized
the Czech crisis and appeasement with
one of his most quotable lines addressed
Chamberlain you were given the choice
between war and dishonour you chose
dishonour and you will have war
so I really hope you found that video
interesting if you did you know what to
do hit that thumbs up button below and
don't forget to subscribe when you're
subscribing make sure you hit that
notification bell so you actually find
out when we put out a new video and as
always thank you for watching
[Music]